The Joe Rogan experience.
Why you getting punched in the head?
What is going on with you?
I'm not getting punched hard.
How hard.
I mean,
sometimes there's a,
then my buddy Chris from Boston is a giant and heal by accident.
Sometimes you need to get connected and stuff,
but now you know,
you learn how to kind of keep your hands up,
but you're getting older.
You're worried about that.
I'm insecure,
Bro.
But are you worried about your brain?
I sure and rattled.
I was a little cloudy.
I stopped for a little while.
Yeah.
So you're getting cloudy from getting hit.
I don't know.
I said to Brendan,
I said,
you know,
he has no time for this shit.
He gets so mad at me.
He just goes,
you're older.
What are you doing?
Oh,
you're getting that look like.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's what happens.
So keep that shit up,
man.
He storms off.
Yeah.
Well he,
he came to the realization,
you know,
he ducked.
He ducked.
He was,
oh,
I don't know.
He was sparring with Shane Carwyn.
It's not mark hoarding all those guys and,
and throwing up after,
after his training sessions and he played football forever.
I'll be all right.
Yeah.
Well right.
He quit though at the right time.
Is He really did.
Yes he did.
I mean he's fine.
Yes.
He,
he made it out at the right time.
I'm so invested in him like,
like he's my brother.
So whenever he talks about Sierra t I'm like,
I'm like see a CTM.
Like,
no,
you're okay.
Don't worry about it cause you're a doctor.
I go,
you're fine.
I promise it's not going to happen.
I don't like to think about it.
Well I mean he's,
he's honest.
If he wasn't doing good,
he'd tell you,
you know,
if he wasn't feeling good,
that's already true.
I think everybody needs someone who they trust implicitly that the can pull the
cord on them and to tell them,
hey man,
you got to stop getting hit.
Yes.
And for young fighters,
man,
it is such a hard decision to make.
I've talked to several guys who have to tell their fighter,
several trainers that have to tell their fighters to retire.
And it's never easy.
It's never easy.
And sometimes identity,
the fighter will leave and go with a different trainer and be successful and,
and the,
the,
you know,
and this one case,
the trainer was like,
I wish him well,
I'm an,
I'm sure he can still beat guys.
That's not the problem.
The problem is he's showing some obvious signs of deterioration mentally,
neurologically,
the way he moves,
the way he talks.
And a good person who cares about,
she was going to go,
okay,
we had a lot of fun.
It was a great run.
You're fine right now.
Like you can talk and we can treat whatever problems come up.
Apparently CBD is fantastic for that for a lot of people with brain issues and a
lot of,
you know,
inflammation issues because of trauma.
There's a lot of stuff they did,
I don't know,
magnetic stuff that pads and gone,
oh,
did right doing down in San Diego on soldiers where they put the electronics
guys doing that right now.
Seal Guy.
Yeah.
But I,
I,
um,
I don't think I've ever met a fighter who is retired who doesn't still feel like
they could fight for the belt.
Oh yeah.
They all want to give it up.
Even Chuck Liddell,
when he did fight and the kid was like,
I'd like to throw my hat in there.
I guess John Jones,
I'm a pretty good wrestler.
Like he was already 48.
Yeah.
You never lose that.
Part of what makes you a great fighter and a killer is that,
that's sort of love of the game.
If you asked Polly and how's you right now,
I guarantee,
I guarantee if you were like,
could you fight for a title right now?
He goes,
I thought,
put my ad in there.
Yeah.
Fighters like that.
Of course.